getting last in there I'm gonna have
some fun I know that I'm pretty much all
it's standing between you and beer so I
should be quick make sure we get you to
the front of the line
this is I have not I did that last year
when I was here who was here last year
Oh lots of hands did we catch that
history Annette talk I did all fantastic
okay this is not that talk but there
seems to be an interest in me acting as
historian lately and so I was asked if I
could do a history of web development
I'm like yeah yeah I've been through a
lot of that too
plus I'm a good researcher that's my my
pleasure and so it was an opportunity to
gather some notes and to remind myself
of some old things and I've this'll be a
little snap and nostalgic and for those
who don't know I was born down here I
was born in in in Turanga and New
Zealand having Kiwi passport I have a
Canadian one as well I live in Canada
now and this is my place the buy place
actually on the left my neighbor's house
on the right this is British Columbia
and this is about 6:00 in the morning on
a Wednesday Wednesday is garbage day so
we have visitors that the check to see
if we put out our garbage early now this
particular fellow is a male he's about
250 kilos and he's a good bear because
if you do put your garbage out early he
will simply open the can take the bag
out and do go back into that ravine so
basically the bear takes your garbage
out for you he's still standing right at
the edge there he's sort of looking over
the cul-de-sac beside where he's gonna
go next because he's disappointed I
didn't put my garbage out Earl but he's
a regular visitor this is taken from a
nest cam we call this camera the animal
highway last week there was a mom and
two cups they came to basically that
same point and then watched and decide
there's too many people in turned around
I went back the other way and I've also
got shots of coyotes and raccoons and
skunks and deer and bobcats
and the occasional domesticated cat
going what the heck am i doing outside
because it's pretty dangerous out there
so that's living in British Columbia I
my first line of code in 1977 which is
not the most important thing to happen
in 1977 the most important thing is Star
Wars wrote that line of code it was ten
print hello world on a trs-80 model one
for ki ram set tape player 127 by 47
resolution and a version of basic not
written by Microsoft it was a tiny basic
and it only had three error messages
what how and sorry
which is the best error message of all
time very Canadian error message to a my
dad what's object not found but sorry so
I've had a long career it's over 40
years now I've done a lot of different
things in technology one way or the
other you may know me for making a
certain number of podcasts and he dotnet
rocks listeners Wow awesome
so we're recording down our rocks down
here first time since I think was tech
ed 2009 was last time we made shows in
Australia so Carl started dotnet rocks
back in 2002 these are free to download
podcast we put up to a week yesterday we
published episode 15 82 so there's a few
of them don't listen to them all it's a
long a it's a long time and some of its
not real relevant you know but if you
want the entire history of Silverlight
top to bottom we have it in shows so
from the happy announcement to the what
the heck happened like we've got all of
that I also make an IT Pro related
podcast called runners radio we just
published his 600th episode started in
it's every Wednesday since April 11th of
2007 and for a brief interval when we
weren't sure if dotnet rocked anymore we
made a show called the tablet show that
was right after build in 2011 when we
were all kind of freaked out and then we
were talking about iOS and Android and
cross-platform stuff we made a hundred
and thirty of those and then we rolled
it into dotnet rocks when it became
apparent that dotnet still rocked but
we're not going to talk about that today
we're gonna talk about the Internet this
is a ping map from 2012 of all the IP
reachable addresses it's nice to see at
least a part of Australia lit up there
kind of the edge of the Internet really
some of these islands in the middle of
nowhere are pretty interesting that they
have they have IP addresses they got
cables right into them
one way or the other and we know that
the internet existed well before the web
did although most people just can't
think of the internet without thinking
of weapons certainly the mortals when
they can't find therein an explorer icon
say I broke the Internet
all right the web is simply a service
that travels over the Internet and we
started by this young man Tim
berners-lee now Sir Tim berners-lee with
his order of the British Empire who in
1989 being a researcher working at CERN
so he was a programmer working for
physicists at CERN and one of their big
challenges was managing all of these
research papers that they were
connecting to each other and try and
understand them so he really had that
core idea of I want to be able to share
scientific papers linked together
through their footnotes that that that
core idea of the hyperlinking this is
actually a later somewhat later picture
but not too much later because he has
hair
he wrote that original version so you
got to think about this guy took on that
I want to be able to to have a service
that will allow you to connect these
documents together and then have a
client that can read them and do that
into relations so he had to write
everything he did it on a next which
means clearly he was not paying for the
computer himself this is this was Steve
Jobs his project in between being booted
out of Apple and coming back to Apple it
was it has a magnesium case because
that's a good idea and it was mostly
sold to academics with outrageous
budgets and that's where we largely saw
these machines the operating system
would eventually become what we'd known
as Mac OS this is actually a picture of
Tim berners-lee's
actual machine that he raid ran the
first web server and the first web
browser on and then there's a sticker on
there's a little partially ripped off
you can go see this machine by the way
it's still at CERN it's behind glass now
that sticker actually says this machine
is a server do not power down because
there was staff at CERN that would go
around turning off all the desktop
machines that people had forgotten to
shut off and that's really bad for the
web when that's the only web server in
the
world this is the very first webpage
notice a distinct lack of porn
in fact this additional format is
modified sgml that would eventually know
as HTML didn't have image tags yet don't
worry they're coming there's not a lot
to talk about this very early stage of
the web it was very much an academic
tool obviously you know started at CERN
it's spread now the earlier stages of
the internet when we're still in the pot
private we're still in that private time
this is a DARPA initiative they're
moving a lot of nuclear weapons
information around it it's tied between
universities and military sites and so
they adopted web fairly quickly so for
me having played around computers since
the 70s
my first experience is touching the
internet was by stealing bandwidth from
internet from universities they were
remarkably insecure we'd go dumpster
diving just looking for reams of paper
and they'd literally be printed out
usernames and passwords on them and that
would get us logged in to you through X
14 protocols and eventually get us onto
the internet such as it was and but a
long time later before we'd actually
have a browser to play with it was
mostly text-based
one of the very first browsers you'll
ever see came out of a university
actually the the National Center for
supercomputing computing in
urbana-champaign and this was mosaic now
there were some text base browsers early
on but this was one of the first graph
of the ones one of the principal
developers behind this was a young man
by the name of Marc Andreessen and Marc
would quickly figure out that this was a
huge opportunity and he would start a
company called Netscape and they were
trying to commercialize these early
versions of the browser and he did want
to try and sell the browser he didn't go
well for him but you know this is the
beginning of what we'd eventually call
the dotnet com boom although this is
before that in 1994 and it's still the
Internet is very much a university thing
and a government thing 1995 is when all
that changes
so now the US government takes a certain
number the the National Science
Foundation net stuff off of the public
Internet they stop putting government
funds into it they make a deal with what
will ultimately become the management
committees still us control but
independent and they make
commercialization legal so 95 is sort of
the turning point of a commercial
Internet and this is when the various
connectivity services that existed ahead
of the public internet like AOL and
CompuServe provide gateways into the
Internet so my AOL account is 103 zero
five five comma 1,500 and I pray someday
I will get those neurons back that I
still remember that useless useless
number but you know we had our own
networks to surf and to connect to via
our dial-up modems and then bit by bit
this internet got made available to us
Microsoft jumped on board with Internet
Explorer this is actually IE 3 on win95
it's 1995 bill realized that the
internet was gonna be a thing he didn't
buy into it at first he was he thought
that the cable companies were gonna be
the way his go is gonna be interactive
TV that's what Microsoft was focus on
was interactive TV but when the
commercialization of the Internet became
possible we came where became legal in
May of 95 he released a paper internal
to the company called the internet tidal
wave and when it basically said was
everybody needs to stop what you're
doing and make sure that your product
works with the Internet in some way this
is when cool wonderful things happened
like you could output sequel query to
HTML did you know cuz Bill said you had
to incorporate some internet technology
the sequel seems like I know we could do
I mean it wasn't a good idea
it's just shows the power of Bill that
when Bill says we all go that way
everybody went that way by 95 we did
have HTML to do
Gmail - had clearly the most important
feature in HTML which is tables and you
can do everything you need it in tables
so it's been fun to find it find a
graphic of tables this is once
apparently from 97 so that's what we get
out of a chair l - all those really HTML
2.1 if you want to get technical about
this and i bump into people who do get
technical about this sort of thing but
it's not very early HTML we do have now
images and we have tables
that's fine on the front end what are we
doing on the back end
how are you programming the backend the
web servers of the day largely with
languages like Perl pearl looks like
cartoon swearing what's beautiful about
Perl like a chunk of code like this is
that there's way more spaces in it than
we need to we could make this all one
line if we actually wanted to and this
is begins a long history of the web
depending on write once read never
languages and don't worry we're not done
yet
there's going to be many many more but
Perl is one of the first scripting
languages for doing back-end programming
writing 95 but it's not the only one
there are a bunch of things that get
launched all at the same time in 95 they
weren't particularly popular or relevant
but they all start right then ColdFusion
by group called a lair actually starts
in 95 it'll take a few years to catch on
and it's good enough that it and you'll
good to see this theme that happens in
these early internet technologies again
remember dot-com boom right this is
what's coming it's 95 96 97 the dot-com
booms coming in we all know when it ends
and so ColdFusion starts out on its own
but by 2001 it'll be acquired by
Macromedia just in time for the dot-com
bust and then acquired by Adobe because
that's where good software goes to die
the original versions of ColdFusion were
actually written in C++ although they
eventually implemented both a Java
version and a dotnet version and it went
over to source in 2008 PHP starts in
1995 Erasmus lured ARF was a young man
who wanted to maintain his homepage and
he was tired of writing
Perle and so he created a set of tools
largely written in C that he could call
into for his personal home page which is
why it's called PHP he was just trying
to make a personal home page and it got
way out of control
within a couple of years he simply
admits look I just wanted to maintain a
home page I don't know anything about
making languages in which the rest
community said we can tell but better
language people will come along and turn
PHP into another well-known extremely
popular write once read never language
also in that timeframe we start seeing
the beginnings of programming
environments that will depend on for a
long time first version is a Java come
in 95 and they quickly jump on the
internet bandwagon with a concept called
applets and servlets again not good
ideas but they were trying Microsoft
will try it with their comm technology
which at this point they'll have
rebranded active X and in fact they'll
brand everything they can find with an
ActiveX for a while there including
creating an ActiveX component you can
put Internet Explorer if you really want
to build a page that nobody can stand
other important technologies in that
time span
Macromedia will start working on
shockwave they'll also have another
company they acquire called futuresplash
and they'll kind of pull off stuff
together and call it flash which of
course will then get bought by Adobe and
killed by Steve Jobs JavaScript will be
named because it has nothing to do Java
whatsoever so Brendan Eich actually
worked for Netscape and they realized
they needed a glue language they needed
some way to sort of pull these pieces
together and the apocryphal story is
that the prototype of javascript was
assembled in ten days which explains a
lot it was originally called mocha then
they Charlie tried to call it live
script then some marketing Jesus decided
attach it on to the Java bandwagon
because that's not gonna be confusing
for anybody
we get our first serious web servers so
Microsoft jumped on board with that
internet tidal wave within t35 one
that's the first version of Internet
Information server literally right at
beginning in 95 Apache I think is cool
about Apache is it is kind of an emerged
product so in those early unix days in
the NCSA the same place where they did
mosaic there were a bunch of scripts you
could run against a UNIX machine to
create something that would act as if it
was a web server literally it was a set
of patches and so somebody said are you
going to run that patchy server yes yes
this is a very patchy server and so they
they've tied it to the First Nations
group but I'm telling you it's name is
actually it's a patchy server and will
of course spawn the foundation and I put
these two right side-by-side as
equivalent to each other for everything
that's right and everything that's wrong
about it both these tools ended up being
these Swiss Army knives of everything
you could imagine you might need on the
web except that all the knives are out
and so you can't help but poke yourself
when you try and pick it up
but it was the beginning of the public
Internet in the beginning of the web and
so we were all just trying to make stuff
work and so having services on you know
this is a technology that came out of an
academic world that just had no
consideration for security of any kind
and we're still wrestling with the
consequences of that other great
technology was developed the same time
period whoo so Vermeer in Massachusetts
actually in 95 built the first there
their first prototype of this WYSIWYG
web page editor because nobody knew what
good HTML look like anyway Microsoft
buys it by 97 and rides that horse for
about ten years
because front-page extensions it's a
good idea maybe a little bit more loved
technology and round that same time
Dreamweaver which will be acquired by
Macromedia and then of course
Media acquired by Adobe I still meet
people who who have fond memories of
Dreamweaver but I feel like they're like
your cartoon that you loved as a child
keep that memory because it's a lie if
you look at it now you're it's like
Kentucky Fried Chicken we all loved
Kentucky Fried Chicken as a kid have you
had it today keep your memory and your
memories better by 97 we get our first
version of Visual Studio Microsoft has
this idea that we should consolidate all
these different development tools that
they're building the visual studio ide
is actually written by the visual inner
dev team which explains a lot
the goal of course was to make a unified
IDE environment for all these different
tools that microsoft made they will
never achieve that goal when they
shipped Visual Studio 97 yes it had a
unified IDE that both inner dev and j+ +
used Visual Basic had its own IDE that
just ran from inside the box so did Fox
Pro so did C++ and they'll make another
version it'll do the same thing again
it's only when they go to dotnet that
they actually consolidate the IDE s but
we do get active server pages so they
found a way to deliver us calm in a form
that was a little less painful and
ActiveX controls on a browser so by iia
we get the first version of active
server pages in 96 in I is 3 and then
second version 97 is for the final
version in 2000 and is 5 and then
asp.net will takeover and we finally get
the w3c and the w3c gets together and
says we need to make some standards
around HTML so we're gonna start with
the first version 3.2 showing that it's
not just Microsoft that cannot number
things so initially Netscape pretty much
built that skate about HTML 2 right
that's where you see that version of
HTML
they then for who got involved with
creating a committee process to try and
have a standard set of HTML or cards and
this
really we're inventing the way that we
set these standards and all we knew for
sure is we looked at the sequel
standards body and said don't do that
so they set out a set of requirements
and set a deadline for all the things
you need to deliver for the next version
of HTML so the next version of HTML was
going to be three except the deadline
was set in such a way that nobody
delivered anything on time and rather
than fix their rules they just declared
version three dead and tried again and
three point one failed also three point
two is the first time that enough people
actually submitted their the
specifications they wanted to have
assessed that they had a quorum so they
could now argue about it so it took
three tries to get to the argument
that's how well the committee worked now
the real question is does it make sense
for a group of architects to sit
together talking through the structure
of a language or should you just build
it and see what happens and that battle
went on and continues to go on in how we
create languages Netscape got tired of
waiting and just started making HTML
three things and when the committee
changed the number they would just
change their number and keep going one
of the great examples of this is Ajax
because H ax is still not a ratified
specification to go to the w3c all right
they've reached the initial prototype of
Ajax but we would eventually call Ajax
which originally the XML HTTP requests
is implemented by Internet Explorer
first why because the exchange guys
wanted to build a web client for
exchange and so they took advantage of
the fact that these guys are like in
buildings next to each other and what
binds it hey we really want to be able
to pop a little thing you've got mail in
our web client could you add to ie an
ability to sort of make a request and we
could tell it got mail and you could
draw something on the screen and they're
like okay they just added it to IE now
we've gone a lot further on that
concepts than them but because it never
went through committee in first place I
think everybody's still resentful of the
fact that they've it's never been
ratified its 2018 it's 20 years ago we
had Ajax of the starch
it's still not been ratified so we
actually ratify the specification of 3.2
in January of 97 and then we immediately
hate it and start working on the next
version by December of 97 same year we
have HTML 4 which we hate so much that
by April of 98
we have 4.01 because spelling mistakes
in the specification okay now I don't
like this once upon a time you put these
on your web page right Lisa I grab
that's where you get these symbols from
that's like yeah we're HTML 4 when the
HTML 5 came along they built a much
nicer graphic so you know I like this
one better although this one's kind of
you know because it's got that implied
table in there my favorite version is
actually about a guy named Maurice
melkor's it's like well if you want to
actually correct the logo it should look
like this
that is the proper HTML for a logo but
that's not the important thing that
happened buying it you think about this
we had a specification that people
essentially agreed on in april of 98 20
years ago for HTML 4 and it included CSS
so you knew it was gonna be awesome
this is the best mug in the world
everybody needs to own this mug also in
98 we get the next version of visual
studio which everything is numbered 6
including the second and last version of
Internet the third and last version of J
plus plus because numbers are hard but a
more important thing that happens in
visual studio here actually is that this
guy joins Microsoft mr. Guthrie's first
and only job out of university is to
work for Microsoft and he works on
studio 6 he actually works on the NT
option pack he had his choice of jobs at
Microsoft believe it or not I've had a
good the opportunity to talk to him
extensively for the book that if someday
I'll actually finish writing
he was convinced to work on the NT
option pack but they suggested at the
time it's like we know we need to change
this fundamentally we know that the way
we're currently doing web development is
wrong so while you're working on this
they wants you to start thinking about
it differently now he came in an early
98 and worked on it so they were already
well underway they shipped studio 98 in
November of 98 and the apocryphal but
true story is dant when they ship at the
end of now at the end of November they
normally took a couple of weeks off
after your ship a product like that it's
hard work right and that basically ran
into Christmas so most of the team took
all of Christmas all of December off but
not our young mr. Guthrie being a young
man who did not want to go back to North
Carolina for Christmas he worked through
the whole thing he now had his idea
mostly he knew how much he hated active
server pages and I also had the good
fortune to have actually looked at he's
when I sat down to do interviews with
him about the history of dotnet he
brought his paper notebooks from 1997
with him he has them he offered them to
me I'm like needs to be in a museum
don't give to me
should be under nitrogen the pages are
starting to turn yellow but I literally
have I have seen the original drawing of
request and response and that's what he
was thinking about was how do we build a
way to program web pages where the
programming language that we use is
object oriented top to bottom and allows
us to interact with the web page in a
much safer way type safe way a
constructs safe way blue screening is
not a strategy he gets a prototype
together more or less in that period in
December he took a break and went skiing
on like Christmas Day that's about all
he did and in January he shows off the
prototype calls it asp plus and the
programming language that you would use
is any guesses
it's Java it's J plus plus because
that's the only object or any language
Microsoft had at the time Visual Basic
does not count
and they said that's cool you can't use
Java the lawsuits already been filed and
and without that lawsuit c-sharp never
would have happened but you know they
that's the path they were on you know
what's issuing about c-sharp is that's
the first and only language Microsoft's
ever invented from scratch they always
implemented other existing languages it
was only because the situation was
sudden that they were basically putting
as they needed to make a language now
that's not the only thing that's going
at the time in Microsoft space biocked
August of 98 mr. Gates's hash to go
before a Senate committee you can watch
this Senate discussion on youtube if you
care to it's a I'm pretty sure that
before Mark Zuckerberg went before the
US Senate he watched all of this with a
group of people pointing at his saying
don't do this this is a mistake because
the Senate came down pretty hard on him
and I have a I have a picture of a Time
magazine cover that I used from 95 where
they call Bill the master the universe
he's like balancing a five and a quarter
inch floppy on the end of his finger but
in 99 that's the cover of Time magazine
because he had Microsoft gets declared a
pernicious Vanna Polly in order to break
up into two companies an operating
system company and in everything else
company now that doesn't happen you know
Ballmer will take over
he was successfully over almost two
years negotiate the consent decree but
the w3 is not done because now that
XHTML 4 is ready and being worked on
it's time to put a little XML on it this
is our XML fever time and so by January
2000 we have HTML 4.01 with XML 1.0 it's
just proof that not everything Tim
berners-lee says is the grace the best
idea I've ever heard right but they call
it XHTML so you know we talked about
Microsoft's lost years this is the
Internet's lost years well we went down
this maybe we can make everything be XML
valid remember schemas that was a great
idea
by 2001 we get Windows XP and we all
have fond memories of Windows XP because
we're diluted the later versions of XP
are pretty good but the early version
doesn't support USB you know it had a
huge array of problems they got fixed up
there's patches and so forth there's
also when we have the security crisis
where the internet really gets used for
its real purpose which is hacking right
you know in just before XP ships like in
2001 alone that's when you get the antic
Kournikova virus the code red worm code
red to the nimda worm like it's virus
city but enjoy the wonders of a
homogeneous browser and Internet
community right that's the hackers can
hit everything and so by 2002 Gates puts
out another one of his famous letters
like the internet title this one's
called trustworthy computing and it will
lead to XP sp2 but in the meantime we
have Internet Explorer 6 now our
memories of Internet Explorer 6 are bad
and there's a reason the committee's
around trying to improve XHTML the w3c
were struggling with this XML thing they
weren't working on CSS hadn't been
ratified they were sort of stuck and
Microsoft insisted on shipping ie6 with
XP and so because they couldn't set the
standards get it settled they just
shipped the version they had so this is
a version of CSS before version 1 that
was included in ie6 that's part of the
problem right it was non-compliant with
standards the real sin of ie6 is that it
persisted as long as it did now one of
the reasons is that Microsoft stopped
making new versions of browsers for many
many years like they've literally be 6
years and the reason was they took that
browser team and poured them on at a new
project which was the next version of
Windows they actually worked on a
technology called
Avalon which you'll eventually know is
his Amal so while that was being
invented they weren't paying any
attention to browsers at all they were
focused on that problem should why
there's such a long delay here
a reason we are frustrated with ie6 back
in the day is not that it was bad
because it was but because it was
popular and not compliant with standards
we have a new browser like that which is
called Safari of course dotnet does
finally come along by February of 2002
we get asp.net we get c-sharp and we get
a new way to do development right
asp.net becomes this driving force of a
new way to do web development of course
the majority of Microsoft developers are
wind farm developers they've never spent
any time on the web before they don't
really know their way around it and so
Microsoft in their infinite wisdom
creates tooling to allow winform
thinking people to make web pages it's a
very practical decision that makes them
very awful web pages and while they're
neglecting the browser the shrapnel that
was Netscape reforms into the Mozilla
Foundation and produces a new browser we
know it's Firefox first ships in
September of 2002 and it will gain
popularity primarily with the digerati
right this became the developers browser
it actually peaks in about 2009 at about
a third of all the browsers in the world
and it makes all the mistakes that very
successful browsers make and they add
more and more tooling to it it becomes a
better and better tool for web
developers to the point where I remember
opening Firefox and going for lunch and
waiting for everything to patch and you
know we have a new browser for that now
we call it Chrome sorry comes around the
same time 2003 now I'm gonna start to
hit some highlights here important
things that happen in web development
world safaris not important yet it's
just on the Mac and nobody really cares
and you can get IE for the Mac but a
really important thing comes out of a
young man by the name of David Heine
Mayer handset DHH DHH was building
software as a service way before we had
the term software service he worked on a
product called Basecamp email driven
software as a service and he didn't like
how hard it was to improve Basecamp to
it
bass came to innovate on base camp and
so he put together rails he picked a
language Ruby which was been around for
years before but nobody seemed to care
all that much but it was you know a
dynamic language it was fun but rails
was the important part of this whole
thing and of course you did it
open-source and this happens remarkably
fast so he puts out the first version of
rails in 2005 in December of 2005 by the
middle of 2007 Apple includes it with
their devstack Apple and they hate
everybody we also see the first version
of what will eventually become the cloud
the first Amazon Web service is actually
coming out March 2006 with s3 and
eastern - actually the first versions
are 2002 they'll relaunch it with the
new branding in 2002 they were really
thinking in terms of creating ways for
third parties to have stores attached to
Amazon and they weren't thinking about
generic development it's just store
management but after a few years of that
they sort of appreciate this idea of hey
we should let them do anything they want
and so 2006 is the relaunch of that idea
so you want to so you'll want a web
server well stand up your own run it in
our environment also in 2006 Microsoft
realized hey maybe this Web thing is
going to be a thing and they make a new
conference called mix what did they
announce it mix they announced in an
explore seven now I've quietly walked
past other things that happen in this
time span because later on in 2006 is
when they'll ship the the operating
system that won't be mentioned just why
there is an IE 7 because the Avalon team
got done and pushed it up or over to the
operating system team and they got to
work on a new version the browser to
compete with Firefox and that was IE 7
they also mentioned a thing called
windows presentation foundation
everywhere which is the worst codename
ever now we interviewed Brad Abrams
about this right the very beginning on
Donna rocks and we asked about this
terrible Cody mrs. hook there's simple
rules if you have a cool bike Avalon you
get a terrible product name like windows
presentation foundation
but if you have a terrible code name
like Windows presentation foundation
everywhere you get a great product name
like several light I'm gonna talk about
Silverlight a little later on first we
have talked about this stupid thing now
this 2007 this is not a good phone the
first version was a 2g phone they didn't
even support 3G but it had Safari on it
you can see it right there and Jobs came
out and said if you're gonna program for
the iPhone
you're gonna program in Safari he was
anticipating a better web browser than
he was actually able to make at that
time he was thinking about html5 he'd
seen the future you'll see this over and
over again we predict a few we come up
with a future and then we may want to
make it come true far before it's
actually coming true and I feel like the
phone died after this right because
before the iPhone phones were cool they
had slide-out keyboards and different
kinds of antennas and like you you can
it's a bunny after the iPhone every
phone looks the same it's a slab of
black glass actually the positive thing
I would say about what the iPhone really
did is that it turned us all into
cyborgs we all have digital extensions
to ourselves what we're now seeing
smartphone sales declined because we're
running out of humans that don't have
them and it's like four billion
smartphones the world that's about how
many adults there are in the world again
not evenly distributed but that's how
smart phones are everywhere and most of
time you think about cyborgs you know
you go all science fiction right well
you should be on the inside of you like
well a U and B messes with upgrades I
don't want to have to have surgery every
six months because I want a new phone
but it is important because it
fundamentally changes the web we're on a
path now to mobile being the only thing
that matters in the web Microsoft starts
fixing some of the mistakes they've made
with an alternative to web forms finally
there's an apocryphal story about mvc2 I
don't know if you
this that he wrote it on the way to a
conference it's not true
so the MVC project had been gestating
for a while they were always looking for
an alternative development model for web
pages inside of the dotnet space and the
prototypes they actually used to do some
recruiting I've got it from Phil hack
himself that he was recruited into
Microsoft the first time because of
seeing a prototype of NBC what is true
is that Guthrie decided to show MVC and
write the demo on the way to a
conference hey cuz he the conference he
was going to his conference called alt
dot net you ever hear this we talked
about it a lot on the show so I'll talk
net was this movement to say that
open-source was an evil in the Microsoft
world because a lot of Microsoft dad's
at the time we're only interested in
stuff that came from Microsoft or their
immediate partners you know the
DevExpress is in the Tellarites and so
forth of the world and the idea they
would go and look at SourceForge for
code that could possibly working dotnet
it was in a famine that wouldn't do that
and so they all net not that movement in
the friendliest version I can paint of
it because they were not always that
friendly said hey some of this open
source stuff is good you should use it
and they were very critical of web forms
because it was highly resistant testing
or maintaining in any way an MVC
represented a pattern that could
actually be somewhat more manageable
code and so that's the demo they invited
Guthrie to keynote the first alternate
conference in Austin he said yes and
then showed up with a demo of MVC and
blew them all out of the water because
he's that cool that is seriously cool
and Microsoft will ship the first
version of MVC as an open-source project
under the Microsoft public license
because they still found a way to make
mistakes with open source in that same
time frame we get the first version of
Chrome that's in 2008 so Eric Schmidt
did not want to ship a browser he was
CEO of Google at that time but he made
the mistake for the company maybe was
think of hiring a bunch of Firefox guys
that were frustrated with the Mozilla
Foundation who kept making browsers in
their spare time this is back when
Google had 20% time and eventually one
of the demos of the 20% time was such a
good browsers like okay make a product
and that's pretty much where chrome came
from now you remember the rails guy DHH
David Hanson so David Hanson writes a
blog post in July of 2008 where he says
look I am NOT building any more versions
of Basecamp that run against ie sick I
am sick to death of this this browser is
a decade old and it is wrong he started
the first to say we need to actively
kill ie6 now he's not alone that's in
July so he actually put the blog post
out in July of 2008 he said I'm gonna
phase out support for Basecamp on ie6
by August like next month then when
enough of his customers go no you're not
he goes December but it starts the
momentum by February of 2009 a group of
Norwegian media sites actually go the
step of if you lo Claire try and load
their webpage on ie6 it literally pops
up windows says you're using ie6 you
need to stop here are links to real
browsers go get one and that point even
Microsoft people jump on board Hanselman
Scott Hanselman actually has a blog
posts from that same period it says you
really need to stop using ie6 now the
good news is we have IE 7 but yeah you
get rid of ie6 why did I eat 6 persist
it's because of XP and Vista right
people did not install Vista because
they got scared by it they stayed with
XP in the default browser with ie6 the
average mortal never does anything other
than the defaults and so are you six
persisted and it kept persisting and
really the only reason we got rid of ie6
I believe is win 7 when we finally they
built a version of the operating system
we didn't hate that had a newer version
of the browser we switched now and when
I say we I mean none of us in this room
because we were all running other
browsers right talking about regular
mortals alright so there goes ie6
and now we can talk about silverlight so
the first version of silverlight in
September of 2007 is actually a really a
media player the programming language is
JavaScript they don't actually get in
with dotnet until October 2008 and I
don't know why we didn't talk about this
more at the time but they built a
version of CLR that ran on the Mac that
worked through Safari and that was
astonishing and it just wasn't a big
deal oh by the way you can write this
code in zamel and c-sharp and it runs on
the map tada though fond version of
silverlight the one everybody loves
actually was three and that is from July
of 2007 a 2009 and then it goes on from
there and one of the reasons is so
successful at that time is that
javascript is still a mocked language
right it's not pretty it's still the
glue that Brendan I could sort of
intended to be we were still limping
along with it in a lot of respects and
there were other plug-in models flash is
very popular it leaks memory like a
sieve but active script like these are
ways to build fairly sophisticated
things to run the browser Silverlight
was very much the copy of Flash except
the language was better the syntax was
better and the implementation was better
and so if you could work with browsers
that supported it life was pretty good
and for a long time it was all browsers
but Java scripts not done because an
interesting man by the name of Douglas
Crockford puts out a wonderful book
javascript the good parts where he
actually writes what is essentially a
treatise that says not everything in
JavaScript is horrible yes there are
horrible bits but if you stay away from
those and stay with these other parts it
could be better that's December of 2008
and I feel it's a seminal moment the
people who read this book would take it
to heart and some of them will and start
really trying to take JavaScript more
seriously in the next few years
JavaScript would be transformed in that
same time span Microsoft finally gets on
the cloud with Windows Azure this is
February if
2010 it has sequel Azure in its support
for PHP Java and.net what's interesting
is we really didn't like it if you were
gonna program in dotnet on Azure at this
time you had the web role and the app
role and that was about it
you had to custom write your code to run
in Azure didn't run anywhere else what I
find funny in 2018 is like dude they
were offering a server less in 2010 we
just didn't want it sort of my reminder
that smart people tend to bring answers
but never show their work and what it
really happened to Azure that ultimately
successful is they stopped just showing
you know you're gonna want this okay now
let's go back first you're gonna want
virtual machines and then you're gonna
want some platform services it could we
have service what a good idea just had
to go through the path so often smart
people you know Jobs wasn't wrong about
html5 he's just too early and Asher
wasn't wrong with web role a pro they
were just too early but we have more
disruptive forces in action by 2010 this
giant iPhone arrives now wasn't the
giant iPhone arrived that wasn't the big
deal although tablets were a pretty big
deal and we forget what was going on in
computing at that time in 2010 2010 was
also the era where they were trying to
make the five hundred dollar laptop
they're trying to drive down the price
of laptops and they already get down to
five hundred dollars for a laptop and
they never really got there it was like
700 or so they were terrible laptops
they were all plastic and cheaply made
in the who's crap and then out came this
$800 tablet that was beautiful and that
laptop was doomed so some ways the iPad
saved the laptop because suddenly the
only way you could make a laptop makes
sense is if you spend made it worth
about 1,200 bucks so you made a nice
laptop that's beginning of the
ultrabooks this really came from the
iPad but it's not the important part of
the iPad the important part of the iPad
is that flash killed it very quickly
they figured out that flash murdered the
battery on the iPad and by April Jobs
puts out a letter in the Washington
Street in the
all Street Journal called thoughts on
flash and what he says is the plugins
are bad they're hard on the machine
they're vectors for malware and Safari
is going to block all plugins going
forward we're gonna keep our computers
safe and not murdering their batteries
there will be workarounds there's a
third-party browser you could install
that would run flash you could watch
your battery level go down on your iPad
but that was sort of the debt actually
at that point in April of to 2010
Silverlight is effectively dead we just
didn't know right really has said at
that moment is sir well I will never run
on iOS period she also wasn't true but
that's what it looked like the good news
is Microsoft shipped win Phone 7 also in
2010 we get studio 2010 which was a very
fundamental version of studio they've
now sort of cleaned up everything
happened in silver in with in Vista
around version three three point five
now they're getting to four which is
actually the third version of CLR
because numbers are hard they get the
first version of f-sharp
they get silverlight 4 which actually
was the fourth version it's the one that
now supports chrome and runs out of
browser I would argue from the web
perspective the most important thing
that happened in 2010 is it shipped with
jQuery all right this is Microsoft
taking open source seriously we're going
to include jQuery in the box now part of
what happens doing that is to in order
to deal with all the legalities around
shipping jQuery in the box is they
support jQuery becoming a foundation
which today is now known as a JavaScript
foundation but all of that begins in
2010 this is also when they implement
WPF inside of studio which is a great
way to make studio run really really
slow jQuery had been around for a while
bulletin John Rzeznik did the original
versions back in 2006 it was the
beginning of I in a lot of ways they're
really serious tooling around JavaScript
and Rezac certainly a fan of Doug
Crockford of this idea the JavaScript
didn't have to suck believe it or not
back in that time span is when angular
now angular is an internal project
inside of Google right they they've been
working on it for a couple of years at
that point and I've talked to guys like
Brad green and and and eager mine are
who were advocating for angular being
used more inside of Google until they're
finally cornered by a VP and said if
your tech so good why is that anybody
else in the world using it
well it's only internal well if it's
only good enough to be internal why is
it good enough for my team and they're
basically bullied into releasing it
publicly in 2010 the for the and this
really is an impact on what will become
single page application we also start
getting specifications around responsive
web design now we did not need css3 and
media queries to make responsive web
design out e.com go in go load up the
Wayback Machine and look at Audi Dom's
website from like 2002 it's responsive
if you narrow the window down it will
redraw itself to fit properly in that
window
those guys quietly while selling in a
ridiculously expensive German car wrote
some really elegant HTML going back to
those early days now without a doubt
media queries make response to design
much easier but it had been it took a
while for it to actually matter this is
2009 that we first get these we won't
really talk about responsive design
until the 20 teens 2013 2014 so we're
where the movement towards responsive
design becomes a big deal
tablets are popular we now you know it
was fine when we we had two form factors
we had your computer you had your phone
and so you had your regular web page and
MDOT then the tablet came along and
ruined everything
three sizes so do we have TDOT should we
do that
no no so responsive web design 2009 is
also well it's actually 2011 when we
really get serious but it starts earlier
than that the Battle of the browsers
this was a really interesting time
from a browser technology point of view
this is when the browser maker is kind
of took control of the w3c because what
they did was compete with innovation
they would build features against each
other they would challenge each other to
be better they would send each other
cakes when ie9 shipped the chrome team
sent the crowd a nine team a big
congratulations cake
but amazing things happen in this period
first is we started actually thinking
about JavaScript independent of the
browser so they talked about the v8
engine and the chakra engine and the
nitro engine and really feeding off of
what Doug Crockford was talking about in
that book javascript the good parts can
we make JavaScript amazing can we make
it powerful and this competition between
these different teams they over a period
of a couple of years iterated incredibly
rapidly they started pre compiling
JavaScript to increase its execution
speed they started pipelining they
started using GPUs to do rendering and
they started implementing a bunch of
theoretical features that would be
eventually become html5 sometimes poorly
and sometimes well and for the web
developer we got to experiment a lot
quickly there were new things all the
time we made mistakes chrome shipped a
bunch of features in experimental
versions of chrome that people
implemented as product when they
shouldn't have and when they pulled them
back out it broke the product made a lot
of people angry and so we learned you've
got to be careful how you deploy things
you're not sure you're going to keep but
one of the key things that came out of
this was his idea that javascript could
be more than glue for browsers and the
evidence really came in that same time
spades with node so node it started in
2009 largely against the v8 engine but
by 2011 there was a shocker
implementation it's just this
conversation now of what if we could
build use JavaScript outside of the
browser but more importantly we were
reversing the behaviors of iis and
apache
now there is no knife you have to pick
up each blade one at a time what do you
want to do you literally declare really
building your web service piece by piece
so as much as it was the language it was
also the
Lassa fee only the things I need nothing
else we also got bootstrap so that
everybody could stop thinking about CSS
and Anders hallsburg ships the first
version of typescript and I've had some
great conversation with him about the
motivations around this but bringing
static typing to typescript I mean I
would argue the what was remarkable
about this is this still when
Microsoft's are wrestling over the idea
of open source but they do open source
Atty script and the open source
community embraces it we were not that
far away from Microsoft being the evil
empire when typescript came along and
generally loathed by the open source
community and yet when typescript
arrived everybody in the open-source
community started building extensions
for their libraries to work against
typescript properly very very rapidly it
was astonishing and and I think it was a
talking point inside of Microsoft that
it's like if you make good things and
you make them open source the community
will not automatically droop reject them
and then the angular team picked it up
and said you know this is probably a
good way to build sustainable projects
long term it's a great endorsement but
Microsoft itself doesn't change really
until 2014 when Satya Nadella becomes
CEO of Microsoft but I would argue even
more importantly when they stop naming
stuff windows and started aiming at
Microsoft
it's speaks to a philosophical change
inside of Microsoft that happens in 2014
we finally get ratified specifications
for HTML and CSS and what is now EC 5 in
2014 and CSS is still awesome
and then microsoft says building
open-source projects from scratch they
take electron and they make they make an
editor with it they released it as vyas
code and in it's the second time after
typescript that the open-source
community goes that's just a good idea
and runs with it and so you start to see
this cultural shift happen that
Microsoft can actually play in the open
source community meaningful way and then
they made edge showing that not
everything to do is perfect that's July
of 2015 with wind 10 which still you
know folks different levels of adoption
and edge has its own set of issues of
course they start off actually the the
codename for edge was Spartan and it was
it probably should have been the product
in because it was a very Spartan version
of a browser where less nothing ran it
was too tight and I'm coming in to the
end of my time here but let's talk about
a couple of other the latest checks
stuff that's being talked about this
show to like the progressive web apps so
it was a chrome team
Behrman and Russell that really coined
the term but they were trying to think
about the browser as the host for apps
period what would you need they were
certainly thinking in the mobile context
so dealing with inconsistent
connectivity dealing with back-end
services dealing with messaging and so
forth I mean the primary thing we've
actually done with PW A's is can't find
a way to keep 20 or 30 versions of
Chrome running on your machine at all
times just in case we need to pop up
toast but it's actually more than that
I've just got to start actually doing it
Microsoft puts out core with the MIT
license in June of 2016 and is rapidly
iterated on it by August of last year so
just a little over a year ago we got up
to version 2 which was actually the
third version of core because numbers
are hard the fourth version called three
should be out sometime next year and I'm
gonna pretty much end on this guy
anybody recognize him this is Steve
Sanderson
he works for Microsoft but he works his
own kind of way every time I get a
chance to news videos guys
astonishing this is the knockout J s guy
and this is the JavaScript services guy
and at NDC in 2017 he'd found a weird
old version of c-sharp written in C++ as
an open source project and he took
advantage to have a set of extensions
that existed inside of chrome called web
assembly and he made a version of
c-sharp that kind of sorta maybe ran
inside of the browser and I was there
Dave Fowler was there one of the
smartest web guys inside of Microsoft
and Dave found Steve seth Waris is the
best impression of David Fowler looking
at Steve Sanderson showing the
impossible
Dave sort of looks like this like he's
trying to keep his brain from bursting
out of his head and this is now known as
blazer or razor pages for the browser
blazer
now since June of 2017 when Sanderson
first showed this office very much its
own code other crazy people have rallied
to his cause the most important one
being Miguel de Icaza because the
pipeline for web assembly is through si
so essentially what they're doing is
they're the same way that we lifted
JavaScript out of the browser and said
hey you can run this anywhere well he
now said is the container the JavaScript
sits inside of the browser what if we
could just put whatever language you
wanted in there or anything we wanted in
there and the pipeline into it is C and
so the reason Miguel got involved is
Miguel's got a pretty good version of
c-sharp written and C because
Rozlyn the.net core version of c-sharp
is written in c-sharp she can't use that
but Miguel got involved and this whole
thing accelerated now Microsoft's been
very careful about what to do about
Blazers they've done they've moved it
over to the asp.net project set they're
calling it experimental while iterating
like wildfire but at the same time I
think other people who start and take
webassembly seriously and I pointed at
the Google guys with golang and they're
making a go Lang implementation inside
of web assembly which brings us up to
this idea of what's next for web
development we now have between
progressive web apps and web assembly
our ability to do anything we need to
in any operating environment through the
browser living in the browser security
context which makes IT people happy we
picked the language we want to work in
Wien
javascript is now the most part of a
language runs anywhere we wanted to
Microsoft has bought github and the
world didn't end and while it's
important that they have github and I
don't disagree that they should have
github I'm farming more interested in
electron because electron is desktop
through JavaScript and I can't think of
a better organization in terms of making
desktop better than those guys over
Microsoft so I can't wait to see what
they do with electron I I feel like as
web developers we've never had more
choice you love JavaScript right
anywhere you want you like building web
pages web services write him in any
language you want we're just at the
beginning of this well I've taken you
through just a little over 20 years of
tour and I feel like we're at the
beginning I can't wait to see what
happens next
thanks very much
[Applause]